[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition du grand jt des territoires sur
tv5monde et sur vos chaînes régionales
et locales
voici les titres de l'actualité
nouvelles restrictions et la vaccination
pour seul horizon pour contrer le commis
de 19 associations et médecins se
mobilisent pour vacciner les plus
fragiles
reportage dans l'aube et en gironde avec
nos partenaires de canal 32 et de tv7 et
si les containers d'habitude
transporteurs de marchandises devenaient
des piscines mobile et abordable c'est
le pari fou mais réussie d'un
entrepreneur dans les vosges que nous
fera découvrir les rédactions devient
vos jeux ne connaissent pas la crise les
gîtes et les chambres d'hôtes
connaissent un succès fulgurant dans le
contexte actuel et notamment les plus
insolites d'entre eux que nous ferons
découvrir la chaîne via moselle tv et
puis à la fin de ce journal nous vous
raconteront l'histoire de femmes
d'hommes de famille qui ont connu
l'exode après l'invasion de la france
par l'allemagne en 1940 un travail de
mémoire rendue possible par nos
confrères et partenaires de l'aisne
nouvelle
pour commencer ce journal alors que les
mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent ces
derniers jours sur le front de
l'épidémie et que les restrictions sont
désormais étendues à l'ensemble de la
métropole
la vaccination elle tente tant bien que
mal de s'accélérer dans l'aube
vous allez le voir collectivités et
préfectures se sont coordonnés pour
mettre en place des points de
vaccination éphémère en milieu rural
ceux ci sont dédiés aux plus de 75 ans
en perte d'autonomie
la vaccination se fait sur inscription
après l'envoi d'un courrier aux
personnes concernées
les précisions de la rédaction de canal
32 dans l'aube sur place 2600 seniors au
bois un perte d'autonomie ont été
recensés pour ceux âgés de plus de 75
ans enoh vacciner le département a
coordonné la mise en place d'un centre
vaccination itinérant les seniors qui
viennent en déambulateur avec des cannes
on
avec des bouteilles d'oxygène on en a eu
aussi un brancard donc c'est vraiment
des gens qu'on ait soucis de santé ou
qui sont en perte d'autonomie
cette structure itinérante sera
redéployé ici à brienne-le-château d'ici
quatre semaines afin d'effectuer la
deuxième injection du vaccin riser est
allée de la mi mars à la mi mai d'un
cinq communes du département
cette opération a nécessité la
coordination entre services de l'état
intercommunalité et départements les
publics auprès desquels il ya l'aide
personnalisée à l'autonomie donc le
département assurer le contact avec les
personnes et ensuite il ya toute une
logistique à mettre en oeuvre de la
communauté de communes dispose d'un
transport à la demande donc le transport
kiné il est à disposition tous les
habitants qui n'ont pas de moyen de
locomotion pour venir ici
cette expérience renforcent la
coordination et prépare à la montée en
puissance de la vaccination auprès d'un
public plus large
les personnes les plus dépendantes
immobilisés chez elles ne sont pas
oubliés pour les personnes qui sont
alités qui ne peuvent plus du tout chez
déplacés on a mis au point un dispositif
où là on va vacciner à domicile c'est
encore plus complexe puisque vous
connaissez aussi les contraintes de
manipulation du vaccin finder nous
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de passer le
moins de 50 jusqu'à 60 voire 70 80 % de
plus de 75 ans vaccinée sur les quarante
mille au bois de plus de 115 ans la
moitié sont vaccinés avec les autres
publics prioritaires
cela représente près de 10% de la
population du département et la campagne
de vaccination se poursuit aussi en
gironde
selon l'agencé régionale de santé la
nouvelle aquitaine devrait recevoir 210
mille doses de vaccin par semaine à
partir du 5 avril prochain une dizaine
de nouveaux sites de vaccination devrait
aussi ouvrir sur place mais une fois
encore il est difficile pour les
personnes âgées d'y accéder pour des
raisons de mobilité
c'est pour cette raison que
l'association sos médecins se rend
directement dans les ehpad pour vacciner
les résidents comme vous pouvez le voir
sur ces images de la rédaction de pv 7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest et
regarder
écoutez ses propos recueillis par
françois cau dans la logique
initialement c'était les médecins qui
devait vacciner mais le problème avec le
kaiser c'est cette logistique de gestion
de la chaîne du froid qui effectivement
complexifie pour le médecin généraliste
dans son cabinet de consultation
la prise en charge de ces patients avec
ce type de vaccin les personnes âgées
qui ont également besoin de sourire et
de se détendre durant cette période dans
la région rennaise pour redonner sourire
et joie de vivre
les ehpad foot appel aux clowns c'est
ainsi que christelle se transforme en
rose a le temps d'une visite à reportage
de philippe bertout pour la chaîne tv
air à rennes déguisements maquillages
aux quelques minutes la rose oise
krystel se transforme au rose à elle va
travailler cet après midi à rennes à la
maison de retraite 100 francs soit signé
dans steam mais des fois on n'entend pas
avec les oreilles des fourneaux avec
rosa rend visite aux personnes âgées
avec pour seule mission apporter de la
joie
une super héroïne qui du coup me permet
d'aller partout et d'aller directement
touché le coeur après avoir pratiqué le
chant le théâtre ou la danse cette
animatrice et auxiliaires de vie
scolaire a découvert il ya dix ans l'art
du clown pour le personnel de
l'établissement aussi rosa est une
bouffée d'oxygène après après son
passage et encore dés des retours de son
de sa venue
donc elle marque les esprits par par la
magie qu'elle crée grâce à son
personnage de rose à christelle contrat
tu y anime aussi des stages des ateliers
et se produit dans des spectacles de rue
et le co vide mais tu à rude épreuve
l'économie de nos régions et notamment
les parcs zoologiques
dans la loire les caméras de notre
partenaire tl7 comme vous pouvez le voir
ont pu se rendre dans le parc de saint
martin la plaine
celui ci n'a ouvert que quatre mois en
l'espace d'un an une situation plus que
problématique sur le plan financier
fier si aucune recette n'est enregistrée
le parc dépense tout de même cinq mille
euros chaque jour pour assurer les soins
quotidiens dont ont besoin les animaux
pour dénoncer cette situation le
directeur du parc pierre thivillon a
écrit une lettre ouverte au gouvernement
sur la page facebook du zoo et quand le
sport se réinvente
afin de s'adapter à la pandémie l'équipe
monégasque féminine de volleyball a pu
tester de nouveaux masques lors de son
dernier match
quels en sont les caractéristiques un
sujet de sandrine maigre et d'alexandra
marangoni pour monaco info à réduire au
maximum la gêne occasionnée par le
masque sur un joueur lors d'un match
mais tout en respectant les règles
sanitaires voici l'objectif de ce nouvel
élément en phase de test mercredi soir
au stade des monnaies getty les
volleyeuses monégasque et laurentine
s'apprête à débuter leur match du côté
rouge et blanc avec ce nouveau masque en
question le but de ce masque est de
permettre une grande responsabilité
c'est à dire de pouvoir avoir des
efforts intenses sans être ensuite y est
on est en train de mener des tests avec
l'institut bis cordes de sophia
antipolis avec le professeur aux risques
pour
calculé tous les effets de masse cas sur
le corps les résultats de ces tests
seront connus prochainement affaire à
suivre donc et ses masques été portés au
cours de ce match qui opposait les
joueuses de l'as monaco volé à celle du
stade laurentin peu d'enjeu mais monaco
s'est imposé à domicile 3 sets à 1 match
retour puisque à l'aîné me l'écho avait
été battue est la saison aura donc été
marquée par un verbe s'adapter matches
reportés suspicion de cas gestion des
mesures sanitaires mais de l'avis
général le plus dur aura été de jouer
sans le soutien et l'appui du public
et puis à marseille les autorités ont
décidé de passer la vitesse supérieure
face au rodéo qui nuisent t empoisonnent
la vie des habitants de la ville 33
motocross et quads ont ainsi été
détruits devant les caméras de nos
confrères de la provence un signal fort
et impressionnant comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images
au total depuis près d'un an ce sont 84
motocross et quads qui ont été saisis
par la préfecture de police de marseille
et leur des cloches a sonné en ce
week-end de pâques une formidable
nouvelle bien sûr pour les fans de
chocolat dans les hautes france pâques
rime avec solidarité là-bas
l'association d'insertion le chêne les
s'est dotée d'un atelier consacré à la
chocolaterie
ces derniers jours le rythme de
production c'est bien entendu accélérer
un reportage dans les hauts de france de
nos partenaires de wéo la chaîne de la
voix du nord regard des mendiants au
chocolat noir ou chocolat au lait bush
et ganache spéculoos ou traditionnels
flamands et poule
c'est la dernière ligne droite pour leur
fabrication dans l'atelier du chênelet
un millier sabrina toutes les deux en
contrat d'insertion prépare les derniers
moulage pour pâques
ici on fabrique du chocolat certes mais
du chocolat solidaire cette activité
c'est un tremplin vers autre chose
un emploi ou une formation nous ce qu'on
essaye de faire c'est d'avoir quelque
chose qui va leur permettre
deux sauts valoriser de reprendre
confiance et puis de par ce soit par du
chocolat par la production
transformation alimentaire de la
position de citronnade ou toute autre
activité toutes ces activités là servent
de se remettre sur mettre en route
et puis derrière décrocher
et un diplôme et un emploi à la clé une
formation des prix les personnes peuvent
rester ici jusqu'à deux ans elles sont
accompagnées pour bâtir un projet car
l'idée n'est pas de devenir chocolatier
ce passage par le chênelet doit être une
passerelle pour reprendre confiance ou
se sentir valorisé par exemple je suis
arrivé si c'est en chocolaterie et on
m'a déjà on adore le chocolat forcément
et le fait de fabriquer le chocolat de a
à z c'est vraiment quelque chose de
valorisant
vraiment c'est très gratifiant de savoir
savoir faire ces choses-là en plus du
reste d'un cursus l'an dernier 2000
tonnes de chocolat en produits finis a
été réalisée ici une activité qui a un
potentiel de croissance
c'est quand même une activité qui à
maintes facettes qui peut apporter le
plein de choses aussi bien aux personnes
qui encadrent qu'aux salariés à allier
l'utile à l'agréable c'est un peu
l'objectif de cet atelier d'insertion
une expérience gourmande et formatrice
donc pas que c'est aussi toute une série
de tradition pour les chrétiens du monde
entier
le dimanche des rameaux notamment se
déroule une semaine avant pâques et
marque l'entrée dans la semaine sainte
une tradition célébrer bien entendu en
corse comme vous pouvez le constater sur
ces images de via télé pas aisé sur
l'île de beauté cette journée est marqué
par la bénédiction des croûtes gtc
petite croix fait de palme tressés en
forme de poisson des toiles ou d'animaux
voilà des images devient telle est prise
et je vous le disais l'actualité nous
l'a rappelé cette semaine avec le canal
de suez des millions de containers sont
utilisés chaque année sur les mers pour
transporter toutes sortes de
marchandises
alors quid de leur fin de vie si la
plupart finissent rebut certains peuvent
être transformés en logements et d'autre
mais oui en piscine une jeune entreprise
dans les vosges s'est spécialisé dans
cette activité
alors que le secteur de l'aménagement de
piscines classiques ne parvient plus à
satisfaire la demande
elle a explosé depuis le premier
confinement reportage sur ces piscines
containers de marie danielle rogowicz et
d'hélène le plat pour vient vosges sur
place regarder
le travail de l'acier c'est sa
spécialité est la base de sa
reconversion professionnelle julien fils
de chaudronnier après une carrière dans
la station de ski de veine tron qui a
fermé définitivement ses portes par
manque de neige a décidé de plonger dans
un nouvel univers créés en affaires dru
sa société de transformation de
containers maritimes en piste où est
fabriquée à l'atelier ici donc le gros
avantage c'est que en arrive chez les
gens on prévoit une date de livraison
si on arrive à passer en camion est du
coup la piscine elle a livré le matin à
10 heures et le soir à 17 heures elle
est en nous les containers ont fait le
tour du monde des containers en acier
résistants julien lear en force avec une
peinture thermo laqué et appose à
l'intérieur un revêtement étanche
c'est de la membrane army qu'on peut
trouver comme un peu le même genre qu'on
met en toiture sur du toit plat on soude
le pays c est du coup oui on a fait une
formation avec avec des professionnels
forcément qu'ils nous ont montré toute
leur petite technique
la jeune société réalise du sur mesure
et elle propose également toute une
gamme jusqu'à 12 mètres de long avec
multiples options et couleurs ce modèle
inférieur à 10 mètres ne nécessite pas
d'autorisation de construction julien
fait aussi appel à des entreprises
locales la syrie de faire dru pour les
revêtements en bois
autre atout la mobilité du produit fini
l'avantagé c'est que même un locataire
qui équivaut une piscine il peut acheter
une de nos piscines s'il veut racheter
un jour une maison que 30 sa piscine il
peut partir avec sa piscine c'est
facilement transportable des piscines
dans des containers qui séduisent
après une première livraison le jeune
entrepreneur vosgien a déjà une dizaine
de devises en cours comptez trois
semaines de fabrication prises un modèle
standard environ 13000 euros
regardez maintenant ce reportage
insolite un habitat pour développer le
tourisme et préserver la biodiversité
depuis quelques semaines à gruissan dans
l'aude de curieuses maisons flottantes
arrive au port
il s'agit de la mise en place du tout
nouveau projet d'habitat flottant dormir
au dessus de l'eau avec une vue sur le
port
un reportage d'alexis martin
pour vyas occitanie regarder une maison
volante qui se posent dans l'eau à
gruissan dans l'aude
voici la mise en place du tout nouveau
projet d'habitat flottant ici est donc
construit un village hôtel de plein air
l'idée c'était de dire comment on peut
allier la destination son attractivité
et la croissance économique de son port
de puissance et c'est là qu'on a on a
pensé à l'ebita photo émergents
importants et on a eu l'idée de se dire
on va faire un petit village les îlots
photo anne gresser dans le port car
aujourd'hui l'objectif est d'attirer une
nouvelle clientèle qui reste plus
longtemps qui viennent sur l'allongement
de la saison et qui vient passer le
séjour expérientiel où ils vont pouvoir
parce que les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui ça ça compte beaucoup dans
la communication raconter leurs
histoires à conter leur à cause de
soucis notre en
ces habitations ne sont pas fixées elles
réagissent comme un bateau et sont même
équipé d'un petit moteur afin de pouvoir
être déplacé
pourvu qu'il y ait un raccordement
électrique et en eau cette méthode
permet d'éviter la création de
plateformes en béton et ainsi être plus
écologique et respectueux de la
biodiversité du port de gruissan soûlé
loach boat on a équipé avec la société
écossais ans on a équipé les lèches
bottes de bio est qu'ils sont des
casiers qui favorise la reproduction des
poissons en permettant aux petits
poissons de devenir se nourrir et de
grossir tranquillement à l'abri des gros
donc là nous sommes à bord du nouveau
coach boat modèle family deux chambres
lits un projet à deux millions d'euros
pour l'office de tourisme comptait 90 à
220 euros la nuit et surtout de ne pas
avoir le mal de mer tourisme toujours
avec un zoom cette fois ci sur un
secteur qui pendant cette crise
sanitaire tire son épingle du jeu
les gîtes et les chambres d'hôtes en
moselle les réservations sont au plus
haut et notamment les hébergements
insolites dans une bulle ou sur une
péniche comme vous allez le voir avec
ses explications de jean mi longs pour
via un modèle très regardé et si vous
veniez passé la nuit dans une péniche
bercé par l'eau ou encore à la belle
étoile dans un dom
depuis un an malgré la crise ce type
d'hébergement dit insolite connaît
d'énormes succès et c'est pour cette
raison qu ici on a décidé récemment
d'installer cette demi sphères on a
prévu un monde
un poêle à pellets pour les soirées
fraîches pour pouvoir le proposer tout
au long de l'année en fait une petite
table avec avec des chaises si demain un
pouvoir prend le petit déjeuner avec la
vue sur la nature en plein travaux
difficile de s'imaginer le résultat pour
cette structure confectionnés dans un
atelier alsacien n'a déjà dû débourser
près de 8000 euros
un investissement à hauteur de la
demande conséquente
c'est important les gens ont vraiment
besoin de prendre l'air de couper
certaines personnes n'ont pas la
possibilité sur un appartement en ville
peut être mieux que quelque chose
d'original
une nuit qui sort de l'ordinaire isolé
loin des foules en plein milieu des
champs et en plus de ça en très bonne
compagnie pour cette escapade
il vous faudra débourser 120 euros
si vous préférez l'air marin vous
trouverez peut être votre bonheur à deux
pas de chez vous on est dans la
timonerie et c'est l'accès pour la pour
la chambre d'hôtes
donc les gens accèdent par ici et c'est
un côté très très traduit en fait que
les gens aiment bien on rentre avec et
en à la barre on encore la vhf les
commandes des gaz
tout fonctionne c'est un bateau qui
fonctionne ici samuel n'a pas eu un
week-end de répit depuis bien longtemps
la chambre d'hôte grâce à son univers
cartonne il ya une clientèle pour pour
ces hébergements insolites une clientèle
qui est depuis quelques mois beaucoup
plus local et qui réserve de courts
séjours d'une ou deux nuits
cette fois il faudra compter environ 90
euros le prix à payer pour prendre le
grand large et s'offrir une parenthèse
loin de tout notre rendez vous éco
région avec vous à présent me fais picot
bonjour aujourd'hui nous partons sur la
côte d'azur pour découvrir une start up
très innovante avec ses lunettes de vue
connectés et surtout intelligente un
bourgeon sert il bonjour à tous
voici une start up née à nice s'est
installé aujourd'hui à sophia antipolis
elle s'appelle elle si elle s'y est là
où les géants comme google se sont cassé
les dents et bien cette petite start up
française est en train de les dépasser
avec des lunettes de vue connectés et
intelligente leur coeur de métier ce
sont les capteurs pour sa première
création elle a mis au point des
lunettes qui ont la forme de lunettes de
vue classique destinée à empêcher
l'endormissement du conducteur au volant
grâce à des capteurs qui sont capables
de détecter les signaux indiquant une
envie de dormir mais ces capteurs
laurent permis de faire d'autres choses
d'autres lunettes par exemple lunettes
qui permettent de détecter les chutes
mais leurs solutions sont aussi capables
de mesurer la température corporelle
voir le rythme cardiaque de manière non
intrusive et ils sont allés encore plus
loin en mettant au point un capteur
capable d'analyser le suivi du regard au
volant pour être sûr que le conducteur
regarde bien la route et pas son
téléphone mobile
sinon les lunettes le rappel à l'ordre
avec un système d' alerte mais ces
capteurs suiveurs de regards sont aussi
utilisés par l'armée
et ce sont les pilotes de rafale qui
commence en être équipés par ailleurs en
allemagne des tests sont actuellement en
cours dans un hôpital pour suivre des
personnes souffrant de la maladie de
parkinson
un proverbe dit que le regard ou les
yeux sont le miroir de l'âme philippe
peyrard le fondateur de lcl cibdi c'est
lui le regard et les yeux sont le miroir
de notre santé et ce n'est qu'un début
merci michel picaud des images du
capitole dans ce grand jt des
territoires maintenant le monument le
plus emblématique de toulouse est en
restauration depuis le début des années
un chantier de taille retardée par la
crise sanitaire vous vous en doutez qui
vise à sécuriser et consolider les
éléments décoratifs chapiteau et statuts
notamment l'occasion aussi de nettoyer
la pierre calcaire abîmé par les eaux
ruisselantes et parfois par certaines
manifestations notamment celle des
gilets jaunes la dernière restauration
avait été effectuée il ya 33 ans
des images de nos partenaires de la
dépêche du midi vous l'avez vu dans les
titres de ce journal c'est un aspect de
la seconde guerre mondiale souvent
méconnu de l'histoire
la fuite de nombreux habitants du nord
de la france après l'invasion de
l'allemagne en 1940 une période
traumatisante évidemment pour de
nombreux civils que le journal les
nouvelles a décidé de mettre en avant à
travers une série de témoignages
diffusés sur son site internet et rient
jaune au bonjour vous êtes le rédacteur
en chef adjoint de la rédaction de
l'aisne nouvelle
pourquoi avez vous sollicité ces
témoignages bah en fait ont approché
de la commémoration de l'année 40
l'aisne en 1940 subi sa troisième
invasion en l'espace de 70 ans et ça a
été en réalité une catastrophe humaine
et c'est vraiment cette cet aspect là
des choses que nous on a voulu explorer
comment avez vous fait pour obtenir ces
témoignages si rare bien écouter on a on
a lancé un appel un appel à témoignage
il s'est trouvé que les gens nous
proposer de faire témoigner leur leur
mère leur grand-mère leur grand père
les gens nous ont envoyé des textes nous
ont envoyé des documents des photos et
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait en fait
une une formidable demande du public
pour témoigner justement 80 ans après de
ce qui s'est passé pendant cette fameuse
années 40 que racontent ils qui sont ces
protagonistes
écoutez on a rencontré cinq dames qui
avait entre 90 et 100 ans en 1940 nos
témoins ont entre 10 et 20 ans elle nous
raconte des événements qui parfois sont
bouleversants je pense à cette dame qui
nous raconte son bombardement de la gare
de rennes qui était un événement
meurtrier il ya eu plus de 1000 morts
elle s'est retrouvée avec son petit
frère sous les bombardements de la gare
de rennes et son témoignage j'en ai
encore des frissons il est vraiment
bouleversant
est ce qu'à travers cette démarche vous
souhaité immortaliser d'une certaine
manière cette période de l'histoire de
france
oui on est très content nous on est très
fier à la nouvelle de contribuer même
modestement à l'écriture de l'histoire
de notre pays est en tout cas de notre
département
on est allé chercher des témoignages
dont on sait pertinemment qu'ils vont
rester maintenant définitivement je vous
avoue j'aimerais beaucoup que c'est que
ces vidéos soient reprises par le monde
de l'éducation et de l'enseignement
parce que c'est leur vocation d'être
d'être vue pour avoir des témoignages
vivants directe de cette de cette
terrible période
merci eric journaux vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef de l'aisne nouvelle
partenaire du grand jt des territoires
ça fait par ailleurs que ces témoignages
seront diffusés dans votre rendez-vous
territoire de france sur tv5 monde
pour terminer ce journal des images
marine la saison de la ponte des tortues
de mer vient de démarrer en martinique
afin de préserver les eaux de plus en
plus de jeunes s'impliquent dans la
protection de ces espèces protégées et
menacées
il ya quelques jours une trentaine de
bénévoles a été formé au repérage des
traces de ponte
regardez ce reportage de marc olivier
dream pour vyas atv martinique sur place
al'approche de la saison des portes de
tortues marines les passionnés
s'organise pendant huit mois cette plage
va vivre comme d'autres plages les
allées venues de temps tu en martinique
entre mars et novembre trois espèces
viennent et reviennent sous la porte
les tortues imbriquées les tortues
vertes est la plus grosse de son espèce
layton qui lutte pour la trentaine de
bénévoles de l'association roots of the
sea vacin lent mais l'objectif est
d'apprendre à identifier les traces de
chaque espèce c'est vrai qu'on est un
petit peu friands de ces expériences
mission exceptionnelle mais on sait très
bien que c'est le travail de patience
m'intéresser aux tortues marines mais
aussi à l'érosion côtière
selon une organisation gérée par
l'office national des forêts outre ceci
est d acteur parmi d'autres associations
on a la chance d'avoir daniel chevalier
aujourd'hui du cnrs pour evs est
justement à sensibiliser les gens autour
de ça on a besoin d'un maximum de
personne qui puisse à recompter les
plages pour faire ce relevé de trace de
comptes et dont les données sont
essentielles en fait à connaître un peu
d'états des populations émission qui
doivent respecter un protocole de suivi
de portes spécifiques savoir s'il ya eu
des émergents sous le double et petit
ortillon des tortues qui sont aussi
sonné sur la plage on prend la
localisation géographique unis donc
latitude longitude
on est évidemment l'esp est simple la
lutte la verte ou la brique et on
indique aussi l'habitat tout ce qui est
très important pour ce chercheur son
bénévolat n'a qu'un but la formation de
plus grand nombre d'acteurs à la
valorisation et la protection de ces
espèces en voie de disparition
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales ou
sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve bientôt pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]